But monetary policy,
that's,
that's a very good question.
Um,
I think that what the Fed has done so
far,
which is to provide investment banks and
other financial institutions which have
played an important role in the economy
and an important role in the functioning
of the whole credit system,
providing them with access to liquidity
with access to the Federal Reserve's
borrowing facility and some of the
innovations that they have done in that
respect are very good.
I don't think that more cuts in federal
funds rate,
uh,
are called for.
I think there's a,
there's a significant risk of inflation
in the current situation.
And so I think the Fed's monetary policy
is not going to continue to cut short
term interest rates.
Now the problem is that,
um,
that what the Fed did,
for example,
in the case of bear stearns,
I'm providing the and in the immediate
aftermath of the bear stearns collapsed,
collapsed,
providing access to the discount window,
boring facility for investment banks.
That was the right thing.
But that was an innovation and policy.
And what I think needs to happen is that
there needs to be some further thought
given to the supervisory and regulatory
function of the Fed over institutions
like that to go along with this access
to,
to the feds credit
I,
I tend to not see political solutions to
problems like this.
I believe in the independence of the
Federal Reserve,
but what I do believe is that the next
president ought to take some clues from
the proposals that the treasury
secretary and this blue ribbon
commission just put forth to revise the
regulatory system for financial
institutions and the economy.
I think that needs a little bit of
rethinking,
and I think the next president will take
that seriously.
We'll have to take that seriously,
whoever that that is.